from Demon Slayer is an insanely
powerful swordsman who absolutely hates
demons but what if somehow he was
suddenly turned into a demon himself how
strong would he possibly be and how
would this transformation completely
change the story
we have to begin all the way back in
episode one where you absolutely must
still be a human because honestly if Q
isn't here to save tanjiro from his
demon sister then the main character
would probably have died right here
right now and the story would be over
and so let's actually assume that this
all stays the same and you actually
sends tanjiro to meet with this former
wada hashira to begin his training and
now you might not remember but tanjiro
actually spent about two whole years
training here at the mountain so this
would be the perfect time period for use
unfortunate transformation and of course
is also going to perfectly set up the
heartbreaking final battle involving
demon you tanjiro and actually two other
hashira here and so let's imagine that
you somehow ends up running into the
demon king muzon and he would of course
get crushed if he ever decided to fight
at all but let's assume that muzan
doesn't want to weigh such a powerful
fighter so he actually offers to change
Q into a demon
now I have to say that there is
absolutely no chance whatsoever that you
would actually choose to become one I
mean he would literally kill his friends
if they were to become demons but for
the sake of the scenario let's actually
say that muzan forces him to transform
instead of asking politely which of
course would be complete torture for you
but he would definitely survive and
likely try to hold on to his memory of
tanjiro and nizuko and that's of course
because he might think that if nasako
can survive without ever eating humans
then maybe he can be able to do so as
well right well the thing is muzan would
probably anticipate something like this
so during the roughly two to three days
that this transformation is happening
The Demon King is gonna do two things
one of which is gonna be completely
messed up I'm gonna be honest first I'm
pretty sure that he takes you to some
place where he cannot actually kill
himself by going out into the sun right
somewhere like the infinity castle where
he is completely under muzan's control
and second I could see Musa on sending
one of the higher ranking upper Moon
demons to kidnap use former mentor
urokodaki to take it hostage well you
might be thinking well wait wasn't
tanjido still training but let's say
that this happens while tanjiro is away
taking his final selection test
is strong no doubt and he would probably
kill himself before being taken a
captive let's assume that he is not
unconscious and then taken back to muzon
and now this of course means that on top
of being a wildly hungry after his demon
transformation you now has also his
mentor to worry about as well on top of
things and I do think that all of this
pressure will eventually lead him to
break down forget his desire to remain a
good Demon like nizuko and finally eat a
human to stay alive which of course is
going to alter his normally kind of
bland personality quite a bit plus now
that he's a demon we have to ask the
most important question how powerful is
a demon you of course he will have the
ridiculous strain length endurance and
healing that all powerful demons possess
but what about his blood demon art and
of course his new demonic appearance
well keep watching to see his insane
design and your powers but we first must
discuss how his transformation is going
to change the story right away because
remember that this is all happening
while tanjiro is taking his final
selection exam so when he's ready to
fully join the demon Slayers he's gonna
have a massive shock when he learns the
horrible fate of the only two demon
Slayers that he really knows I mean talk
about a rough start to a new job I guess
now there are actually a few things that
could happen next kanjiro might be
desperate to try and save them but
honestly he is nowhere near yet strong
enough to attempt any sort of rescue so
for now the story will progress as
normal that of course means that hanjiro
will still go to mount matagumo to fight
the spider Demon's family but instead of
you showing up to rescue it will
probably be someone else like the flame
hashirarengoku who wouldn't strong
enough to easily take out the lower rank
5 demon but actually while we're talking
about the hashira I do think it's fair
to assume that the other hashira will
not take the news about U's
transformation well at all in fact some
of them like the wind hasidasanime and
the serpent hashirao obanai will
probably even want to go hunt him down
immediately and speaking of demon Q I
already mentioned that eating humans for
the first time would probably change his
personality so at this point he would
probably be losing his grip on his
Humanity completely and be out hunting
down humans and eating them to grow
stronger in other words there is a very
decent chance that other hashiras could
find you somewhere but for now let's
assume that he avoids fighting against
any of the strongest demon Slayers for
now which definitely won't last forever
as we'll see in just a few moments no
worries and now there's of course one
other disclaimer I have to mention and
that is of course because as a hashira
you would probably know a ton of super
secret information that muzan would just
love to get his hands off for example
the location of the Demon Slayer core
headquarters or the swordsmith village
but for the scenario let's actually
assume that demand you has lost some of
his memories because it would basically
be the immediate end of all the demon
Slayers if muzan had the information at
this time in the story and so while
months pass and Demon goo slowly grow
stronger and stronger tanjito goes on
his missions nearly dies multiple times
of course and spends a ton of time
recovering and at the end of all this
you would probably relatively easily
have already climbed all the ranks of
the lower Moon demons and is more than
ready to challenge some of the top 6
spots that's because even though he has
only had a few months to actually Master
his new body and new skills we do know
that insanely strong humans like the
hashidah usually turn into insanely
strong demons with more of muzan's blood
so now demon Gil is ready to make a push
to become an upper Moon ranked demon and
actually in case you didn't know there
isn't like some sort of special
tournament or something like that that
the demons used to rank themselves
instead a demon can only become ranked
by earning muzan's favor and uh the very
best way to do that is to do something
quite extraordinary or just be super
ultra powerful I guess and so to pull
that off let's say that instead of just
killing hundreds of people you trick
someone like the upper Moon 5 demon
gyoko into a fight now we do know
actually that demons can't usually kill
each other and they don't often fight at
all but it does happen from time to time
because we're told in a fan book that
the upper Moon 3 has challenged the
upper Moon one multiple times so let's
just imagine that you insults gyoko's
creepy artwork or something like that
and they square off to fight which means
it is finally finally time to see what
he actually looks like and his new
powers in action
[Music]
this is his new demon form which is
mostly his same human form with a few I
think quite nice changes first off he
has these icy blue lines that cover
parts of his body kind of like cracked
ice he still uses a sword but we'll see
what kind of new blade he has in just a
moment and then to cap it all off he has
this long kind of dragon-like tail now
and we're actually gonna see his new
powers in action right away because when
gyoko unleashes thousands of demon fish
at you the hashira demon pulls out his
sword and the entire group of fish
instantly freezes and I mean they
literally freeze because Goose blade is
actually an ice sword made from his
blood demon art that's kind of because I
ended up combining his normally chilly
personality with his water breathing
form to create an ice blood demon art
which allows him to freeze things around
him which of course is going to be super
effective against gyoko because you can
even make it so cold that it can
somewhat freeze the blood in the upper
Moon 5's body and so with this within
seconds the former hashira slices
through yoko's body and easily puts an
end to this duel which certainly will be
enough to earn muzan's favor and promote
you into gyoko's spot as the upper Moon
5 but before you leaves he makes Kyoko
reveal the location of the swordsmith
village and now if you're caught up with
the anime then you might be able to
predict somewhat where this is gonna go
next because while tanjiro has been
fighting on the Mugen train and in the
Entertainment District he has broken his
sword which means he is off to the
swordsmith village for a new one and at
first all seems to be going well but
after a few nights here things start to
get chilly
because in the original story the upper
Moon Four demon and gyoko actually
attacked the village with the help of
all these creepy fish demons however in
this version gyoko is replaced by demon
you now so instead of the creepy fish we
just have a bunch of random weaker
demons here with us instead however this
Invasion now sends the demon Slayers
into a battle including tanjiro genya
the mist hashira michiro and eventually
the love hashira mitsuri and hold on to
your seats because in this battle we're
going to see one final betrayal that
will absolutely crush your heart and if
you want more Demon Slayer content just
like this you also should make sure to
subscribe to the channel but let's now
kick things off with the first major
change to this Arc because since there
is no gyoko in this battle when michiros
brings back to the Village after being
Blast away he isn't going to be stopped
by the former Moon 5. and that means
that he can basically head straight back
to help genya and tanjiro face off
against the upper Moon 4 hatengu and his
split personal which means that when
nitsori finally arrives back at the
Village he's still be able to slice
straight through the weaker demons until
she reaches the village Chief but this
time instead of being crushed by a giant
fish The Village Chief is already dead
and as she sees this mitsuri's skin
starts to shiver that's because standing
over the village Chief's body is demon Q
with his icy sword covered in blood and
of course this would send mitsuri
absolutely Furious because while I don't
think she would have been one of the
hashira who originally wanted to hunt
you down at this point there is no
turning back for the former demon which
of course is truly heartbreaking because
mitsuri used to actually think you was
pretty timid and adorable but now she is
determined to cut him down but first
Goose dragon-like tail shoots out and
smacks mitsuri out of nowhere and then
the Furious hashira rushes you with her
whip-like sword flashing in a million
different directions but before we can
see the epic climax to this fight we
first have to say that on the other side
of the village the fight against the
upper Moon 4 is going way smoother than
in the original story and that's because
if we're being honest michiro is one of
the strongest hachira and so with him
around huntengu might not even have time
for his personalities to recombine into
the ultimate form before muichiro or
tanjido managed to cut the head off of
his actual body and so with one upper
Moon demon down they head back straight
into the village to find it completely
covered in ice uh-oh now unfortunately
they find random demons still attacking
the village and worst of all demon goo
is standing over the dead body of
mitsuri with his demonic tale covered in
blood okay I guess at this point really
no more sympathy for you he does need to
be killed like now because while you
might say that he was forced to become a
demon in the first place and then
blackmailed into eating humans at this
point I do think he has complete lately
lost his Humanity which really is tragic
because even though I think tanjiro
would still try to turn you into a good
Demon somehow there's really no chance
of making it work at this point which of
course means that they're now gonna
actually have to fight and honestly
there are so many different ways that
this battle could go use blood demon art
is kind of broken honestly with this
kind of icy blade and his ability to
even freeze people's blood to some
degree but I do think that tanjiro and
especially muichiro at this point would
be strong enough to resist both of that
although it is honestly kind of hard to
say if they would win or not I mean like
I said muchiro is extremely strong with
some of the best Feats in the original
story and I would definitely put him
above human gear but as a demon it is
really a lot harder to say and so it's
nearly impossible really to say who
would actually end up winning this fight
but without a doubt it would be a
devastating battle both physically and
of course emotionally for tanzi however
one thing that would have made this
fight way easier for the heroes is if
they had actually had another strong
demon to fight on their side and who am
I talking about well in this altered
timeline it is also possible that the
rengoku actually agreed to become a
demon as well during the Mugen train Arc
and if you want to see demon rangoku's
unbelievable powers and his
heartbreaking sacrifice in that version
of the story you can watch that right
here thanks for watching and I will
hopefully see you in the next one